you can tell that aside from covet
policy there's a shift in political
sentiment on covid from the democrats uh
and you can see it very obviously uh
because as you know a couple days ago
joe biden got coveted now he told
everybody that he got cancer turned out
that that was just because of the
dementia but he did actually get covid
uh and conor put together this great
video what you're going to see here the
first half of what you're going to see
is whoopi goldberg on the view talking
about
donald trump when he got kovid and then
we are gonna juxtapose my favorite word
we are gonna juxtapose that with whoopi
goldberg on the view talking about when
joe biden got coveted
he's the head of the free world so he's
whatever they're giving him
they're giving him to pump him up and
make him look like he ain't sick i guess
he's forgotten he says he gets it now
you can't possibly get it you didn't go
through it you whatever you have or
whatever you got
they got to you and they they gave you
everything you needed to do but
everybody else the rest of the people in
the united states of america don't get
to do what you do
right before the show we found out that
president biden has covert and is
experiencing mild symptoms he's
isolating at the white house and uh i'm
sure we all wish him a speedy recovery
i wish i was isolating at the white
house can you bring me a grilled cheese
i mean the good news is is that he's
double boosted he's fully vaccinated
this is a very situation a very
different situation than when the former
president had coveted before
he was vaccinated and you know
that sort of thing yeah sonny she is
such a dullard yeah that's right biden
is double vaxxed and double boosted and
he still got coveted trump was not
vaxxed when he got coveted and he was
basically back in action 24 hours later
despite the fact that most people in the
media were not wishing him well the
amount of people that were that were
hoping and praying for his death on
twitter and elsewhere was through the
roof but i just wanted to show you that
just because i know you get it but it's
like just showing you the general tone
it was like when trump got it it was
like sort of his fault that he got it
even though he was the guy that got
operation warp speed to get all the
vaccines out there you may not like the
vaccines now or wanted to take a vaccine
but like for these people who are
vaccine worshipers right they're science
worshipers that you'd think they'd be a
little thankful for trump i mean they're
literally saying oh but it's very
different because you know baiden got
the vaccine he's been jabbed 87 times
that had a little something to do with
trump but when it was trump got it it
was like there was a certain anger
towards trump but when biden got well we
wish him well and you know hopefully as
if they as if they let biden hold a
phone to order a grilled cheese there's
no chance in hell